what do you think about these dating
apps because one of the things i've
brought up before is that
when women were in uh you know before
dating apps before websites for dating
a men and women in college together
their dating pool was the same dating
pool for the most part right
20 year old woman no has the same social
circle as a 20 year old man
so the likelihood of her dating someone
within her age range and at the college
is
high with dating apps the likelihood
that she's now going to pulp it up and
find a 35 year old guy who's got a
convertible and an infinity pool
infinitely higher and so it's very
simple it's not that
the woman doesn't like the guy at her
school
it's just that she gets two text
messages one's the 20 year old guy who's
in our class and says hey we're going to
go sit in the train tracks and like
drink 40s
and then the other message she gets is
from the guy who's like hey i'm going to
take the the convertible down for a spin
and go to the beach and look at the
stars and which one she's going to pick
women have preferences so maybe someone
i'd rather take the 40. but i think
there's a tendency
because the wealthier guy the the
established guy
has more opportunities for fun
and excitement and adventure yeah these
college women are more likely to choose
that
it just opened up the world for them and
it's allowed these older guys to get
access to younger women in ways they
couldn't before
sure so that means that guys who are you
know college age right now
gen z they're going to struggle in the
same way in
in a similar way to millennials in that
20 year old
i was talking to a guy a couple years
ago he's like 24 and he was a virgin
and he had no idea what to do right
because no matter what the women weren't
interested in dating him he's a normal
guy he wasn't a creepy weirdo like a
regular guy and i was like bro i guess
at this point he's got to like walk up
to somebody and say hello i'd like to
you know nice to meet you
i live in the area or something like
that and he's like you can't do that
you'll you'll you're like you're crazy
if you do that no no so
okay please keep coaching him
all right we're talking guys like that
years ago so right i don't know
i remember his name so any guy like that
because really that's just an excuse
because he's too shy to go over because
you don't be projected i don't think so
i think you'll you'll end up on on
twitter with someone filming you
calling you a creep they'll post your
picture on instagram and say this creepo
is harassing me
they get points for it i said it's fair
yeah they get views they get likes they
get subscribers
those women are going to be alone then
so that's very sad but i think
that i mean look i i'd imagine the
average woman
would not do that right probably just be
like i'm flattered and have a nice day
yeah not but the but the landmines are
there no sure the landmines
landmines are there for everybody we're
all afraid of something we're going to
say
something we're going to tweet something
we're going to write something we're
going to say
on your podcast your youtube show
but we got to take risks in life because
we don't move forward
without taking risks and in fact
risk taking men are attractive to women
again because they make decisions okay
may i may you know may fail but i'm
going to try i'm going to do it
and that is actually very attractive no
one
not every woman is going to be attracted
to every man i mean a man can come to me
at a party and
kind of say he's interested and i kind
of i don't find him a
you know whatever he's not for me i'm
not going to be rude to him
but it doesn't mean i have to date him
he may get rejected
i could do the same thing to a guy where
necessarily going up to him
hey dude i but you know that flirtation
you start talking and then i could sort
of see he's looking over my shoulder and
which is not so hard because i'm little
and just not be interested in me and
that'll hurt my ego for a second and
then i'll move on
you know dating isn't easy you have to
take risks
and when you take those risks you're
going to end up with probably a woman
that you really want to be with
because that's the woman you were
waiting for and he risked a lot for and
he got rejected for a lot
people you know people well why do these
guys like they're not cute or whatever
it is
they always like you know hit on the
women well yeah because they're used to
rejection
what's one more the good-looking guy you
know with everything going for him
he's rarely rejected so when he sees a
woman he really likes he's
too shy to go up to her because he
doesn't want to feel rejected because
he's not used to that
there's another uh i guess you call it a
trope that
attractive women are less likely to
actually get
hit on randomly because guys will assume
they don't have a chance
so they won't bother and they'll go for
women who are like lower in the ranking
in their minds like less attractive
they'll see it when they're like wow
she's a nine she would never go for me
right that woman's a seven i'll i'll try
and head on her yeah
and so and i don't understand why you're
still single i mean you're gorgeous
you're doing so well in life i mean i
don't know well because
the guys didn't ask me out i mean i'm
talking about me specifically
but like you know yeah well that's why
we have so many women do so well well i
mean she's not going to say yes to me
you know well in fact guys give it a
shot again
women want to know that they're that
they're admired that they're like that
they're being courted that somebody's
interested in them
show you're interested it's actually
really attractive and yeah it doesn't
mean
all the time you're gonna get the right
feedback that you want
okay you move on i went through when i
was kind of
going through that phase where i stopped
talking to really hot girls not stopped
talking but i wouldn't hit on them or
like
try and get together with them because i
thought they probably get hit on all the
time
so i don't want to be one of those guys
so i just completely and it'd be girls i
really
was attracted to but i wouldn't because
i was like i'm not going to contribute
to that
toxic masculine i was like you know 2007
feminist propaganda ian
it was i've had two guys in my life who
i really liked
who like you know five ten whatever
years later
you know like i really liked you but i
was just a little too
i just didn't i'm i didn't ask you out
or
what and i was do i was just dying for
them to ask me out right
so guys take a chance ask the woman out
please
yeah the worst case scenario is that you
end up on some
reddit where they're blasting your face
calling you a creepo out of context
yeah likely all of us in this room have
been in a reddit
conversation like that we are still here
to talk about it
oh yeah i mean me like every day it's
hilarious so now you have something to
talk about on the date
they're going to take this this is going
to be one of the best episodes for the
the grifters because
there's so much to take out of context
that's brilliant
yeah that's why i said you're welcome
when we were when we were talking about
the you know the women
struggling to find men who make as much
money as them like when i
when i did like two segments
in like two days because there was
another story that came out similar that
was similar
feminist twitter exploded and the
funniest thing about it
is that these single women working for
you know these news outlets
immediately went for attacks on my
masculinity
saying you know just insulting me and
insulting things that that
i guess would be offensive to someone
based on stereotypical masculinity or
whatever
and i just like i'm laughing my friends
are like so there's other youtubers like
messaging me sending me
the screenshots and we're like just
laughing crying it's hilarious
because i don't think they realize that
like
i don't i i don't care like if i cared i
wouldn't make youtube videos
like heaven forbid someone who actually
cared about being made fun of on the
internet would actually put themselves
on the internet
i guess there's a lot of people who work
for these news outlets particularly
feminists and leftists who can't handle
it
it's like dude if you don't want to be a
public figure don't do it
man i chose to do all this i find it
hilarious what are they possibly putting
down about your masculinity
no they just do things like they do this
to everybody they'll be like you can't
get laid and they'll say you know like
just you know things like that because i
met your girlfriend and she's gorgeous
in a body i'm saying okay i'm sure i
i i'm not worried about you and your
masculinity but i don't care
and no i i know you don't care but it
makes look this is their content this is
this is what they do whether they're
paid for it or not this is the type of
content that they like to write about
this is what they know
and it's heartbreaking for me because
i i want them to be loved by a man
and i want them to love a man they say
incel right so
one of my favorites is uh are you
familiar with carl benjamin i don't
think so
carl benjamin of the lotus eaters
podcast by the way he's
uh anti-editarian he used to make a lot
of anti-feminist videos
and they call him an incel all the time
a direct attack on his masculine he's
like haha you can't get laid
he's married he has children right same
thing with ben shapiro they're like ben
shapiro's an insult he's like he's got
how many kids does he have now three
three
yeah right what are you talking about i
don't think ben shapiro was insulted by
your attacks on his masculinity he's got
a wife who's a doctor by the way
i heard yes and he has three kids so why
do it's really interesting that they do
this
that like one of the attack vectors for
the this particular ideology is do do
they
maybe it's a caricature you know they
constantly say there's toxic masculinity
and these men are toxically masculine
so because of that they think men will
be insulted if you challenge their
masculinity or like
maleness or whatever you want to call it
they could be projecting
um you know in general millennials and
gen z
are not having um certainly gen z
they're not having
sex um as much as gen x
then i don't not referring about me
because i wasn't either but
in general they're not having a lot of
sex partly because they are
just on the apps or they're too lazy to
actually get off the couch instead of
sex
actually have real sex i am sure i'm i
don't know i'm not a man
i'm sure that it's much more satisfying
for a man to actually have
sex with a woman than to sext her from
his couch
yeah right yeah chances are right so
i look women
as much as women talk about that you
know they
want to have sex like men they just oh
they're gonna they're just gonna hook up
the hook-up thing
truth is women don't really want to have
sex like that
most women do not want that it doesn't
feel good
to you know for a guy just get out of
bed okay well thanks
women have all these chemicals that are
floating around that make them feel sort
of depressed afterward if
they don't feel that connection long
lasting way so
it could be actually that they're
projecting but whatever
it is it just seems like they
um they're talking about the things that
they want most
and that fear is stopping them from
getting what they want i think it's
projection uh there was a story that
came out
i think about a year ago that i can't
remember what it was but it was like the
amount of
men under the age of 29 that were
virgins like skyrocketed by like 30
something percent
yeah and it was like 15 or so for women
meaning women were still able to get
laid but
not with men who were 29 and younger and
so a lot of these
uh socialist types and woke leftist
types who are active on twitter are
younger
you know we we've uh one of the things
that that's come up in conversation with
some of these individuals on this show
is that we realize they're in their
early 20s they're in their mid-20s
they don't have the same political
experience so we're having conversations
about war and conflict and taxes they're
like i don't know occupy wall street i
was you know
15 years old or whatever it's like oh
real interesting so you and
there's things about the 90s that i
don't know because i wasn't you know i
was a little kid back then so somebody
tell me about clinton all the stuff
they're older
so a lot of these people on twitter who
are like democratic socialists who not
and they're not all in their 20s right
but there's a high likelihood
that they're all virgins and because of
that
they feel particularly insecure because
that makes them feel bad
they think saying it to me makes me feel
bad
or ben shapiro who's got children
the hardest proof of not being an incel
literally
conception but they're hurt by it so
they use it thinking it'll hurt you
and it's one thing to say oh well you're
probably a virgin still virgin like you
sound like you're like you're in high
school or something
um i mean just that tone of voice not
that high schoolers are
many high schoolers i hope are virgins
but incel
which is like a dark version of
a virgin version of virgin
meaning they're not necessarily virgins
right they just decide that they don't
they're not involuntarily involuntarily
so something happened
where they're unable and it can become
really really dark
and it can be a lot of these people
could be outwardly dark or inwardly
meaning
some of these people blame society and
blame everybody else and some of these
people blame themselves and think
they're just wrong and ugly and
incapable
yeah well yeah and
we were talking about girls who really
are are mean to other girls social media
um you know because toxic masculinity is
a man
you know punching a woman toxic
femininity
is our girls sort of bad-mouthing each
other
or being passive-aggressive and not
liking the photo
you know like girls are mean in other
ways
um but the fact that they're mean to men
as sort of like why are you doing this
what don't you have other things to do
like this is not a productive you know
thing to do with your life
so yeah guys get off the couch get off
twitter
get off twitter get off everything and
and go ask a woman out on your date
here's the trick yeah here's a trick you
have a dog
no no okay if you're a guy you need a
dog okay yeah here's what you do
yeah you go down to the beach you have
the dog
and there are some you know like women
and you know they're like hanging out
and then oh no the dog
he got off the leash oh rufus oh no i'm
so sorry
he just loves people what's your name hi
i'm tim nice to meet you thank you this
is rufus
correct this is how you do it guys for
the most part women are not going to
destroy you
if you ask them out if you flirt with
them and you know what you should know
if a woman doesn't seem like she's
interested like move on right like don't
harass her i mean we have to understand
that but
also women like if a guy is
if you think he's interesting at least
for a conversation like
don't don't decide you have to marry him
if you go on a date with him
it's okay and by the way dating is fun
gosh you get to go out with somebody
you've never met until recently
and you get to learn about them you
likely you'll learn a little bit about
yourself
maybe you'll have a nice glass of wine
if you're lovely you'll
you'll won't be upset if he actually
points to
how about this bottle of cabernet
sauvignon and you go on from there
enjoy life this is life enjoy it
i got some advice for people who feel
like they're stuck in a rut
go to a mma training gym
maybe it's not good advice because i
don't know much about mma trading gyms
but you can go to like a martial arts
gym i used to live near one and maybe
you're out of shape
maybe you're a homebody who plays video
games you're lost you know what to do
i assure you if you walk into one of
these places and say
i feel lost i lay around playing video
games i want to do better
these guys in there are going to be like
dude right let me show you how to throw
a punch
come here join the crew we're going to
make you and it's going to be a whole
lot of fun
for me skateboarding was always this i
would just show up
everyone's having a good time you meet
people you'll be sitting down but then
i'll tell you this
whatever it is you choose to do in terms
of physical activity and community
and and making yourself better some kind
of physical exercise
you're going to encounter that challenge
so for me skateboarding right you want
to drop in on this big vert wallet scary
you're freaking out i assure you
you fall down from like your first six
foot drop in
and hit the ground and you're sore and
you're okay though
when you're out at the park and you see
you know a woman or whatever you're
gonna be like
i just took a face full of you know
concrete
someone telling me have a nice day is no
big deal so
you build that companionship with
through community by going to
some kind of gym and just sticking with
it yeah and
people like i assure you man most people
at these places are super excited to get
people involved and and help them out
and there it's most people are good
people
and then you build confidence in
yourself by accomplishing something and
improving yourself
and then you can be calm and polite and
go and meet people whether it's a a guy
or a woman
or you know just to be friends or to
find a relationship it just starts
with that job you want start that
company you want
women too and if you don't if you're not
ready to go to the gym because of covid
and you just there's so many free
youtube videos like
i i mean amazing stuff out there you
know
just start a lot you know weight
training is really good it's good for
cognition it's good for how you
feel just start moving and
but you know you know what the big thing
is is being at the gym
with other people totally because
they're the ones who are going to like
one day you don't show up and you're
going to a phone call and they're like
bro
accountable what are you doing
accountability is huge i actually have
two
girlfriends i met at the gym i was going
to the gym before cove at 6 a.m every
morning
had these two girlfriends and we became
friends then this happened so we would
text each other i'm doing
i found this this class online i found
this now i've got these people i used to
you know do we were in a co-work space
together
now we we countability every day we say
okay just did 40 minutes cardio oh i
just did yoga i just you know
wait okay and we give each other like
literally the star emoji because
that's cool so but accountability is
really good so find yourself
accountability friend accountability
coach somebody
who you can check in with and they don't
have to be better than you at whatever
it is
just a buddy that's a good point i was
playing music was mine and singing
because it would get re i would get
ripped my core would get rip when you're
like hitting
high notes and like like brandon boyd
from incubus i mean when you're like
doing that you get powerfully muscular
in your core
but the confidence doesn't come until
you have a communication
friend like a drummer like when you're
in a band and you're
you're exhausted and you're in you're
interacting with someone then when you
see a girl
it's you just do the same thing you've
been doing you're not stressed
because you've already figured it out
but when i was alone singing
i would still i would still be stressed
because i didn't have the communication
friend right
but that's like a partner shows are
similar book a show and then you're
standing in front of you know 70
strangers and you're like oh man and
then you
got to do it sure and but in that point
about you and the drummer right
that's you're you're better at you when
somebody else is in your life
when somebody else you know you need
that connection you need that
you that that energy back and forth and
i'm sure the drummer felt great
because as you're sneaking and he's
going your shoes go i mean that's
that's what creates amazing music and
amazing connections
amazing relationships thanks for
checking out this clip from the tim cast
irl podcast
if you want to see the full show come
back to this channel youtube.com
tim cast irl monday through friday at
8pm where you can leave comments
and super chat and we actually will read
your comments
on the show don't forget to like share
subscribe and if you want exclusive
members only content segments you can't
get anywhere else
go to timcast.com become a member and we
even have full bonus episodes
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time
you